We've helped Grant a ton throughout his journey building up his glasses wiper
and nozzle enterprise. He's doing algebra all the time now to solve problems he
encounters in his business and he knows how to do all of it because of us. He's
been so successful that he was able to afford new office and he's trying to
decorate his new place with art that reflects his products. Although he has
different sculptures and paintings and other masterpieces strewn throughout his
new space, one of the things he is most excited about is this fountain that
looks like a giant wiper nozzle. He thinks he's worked out an equation for the
trajectory of the water coming out of the fountain and then going up, falling
down on the ground. However, he wants us to check that equation for him. Let's
help him see if it's right. Just like we had with Grant's slingshot a few
lessons ago, let's set up a coordinate plane so that the fountain is positioned
at the origin, just like this. Now, I realized that the fountain is not as small
as its single point on the coordinate plane but for the purposes of this
question, let's just pretend like the entire thing is located exactly at the
origin. From this position of the origin, the water is going to shoot up out of
the fountain and then fall and end up slightly over to the right. Here's the
equation that Grant came up with. Y equals negative 7x squared plus 14x minus
10. In this equation, x stands for the horizontal position of the water, at a
given moment, and y stands for a corresponding vertical position for that same
drop of water. So, every drop of water of this fountain should follow about this
equation. Remember, this is just an approximation. We're sort of idealizing the
situation, so just go with it. Now, if Grant is right, then one of the roots of
this equation should be where the fountain is located, at 0. And the other
should tell us where the water lands, over here. In other words, if we saw the
quadratic equation that goes along with this equation for a parabola, then we
should get those two solutions, those two roots. Let's use the quadratic formula
to see if Grant is right. For now, I'd just like you to simplify the parts of
the formula that belong in each of these boxes. Just put a number in each spot.